Hey everybody it's Charlie. time to start the conversation
about season 8 so we could do this for like an hour
long so this is going to be top 10 then we can pick bonus
videos for other really important stuff like all the
Aegon backstory why Jon is named Aegon instead Jaeharys their will be a lot of stuff to get through and I
will still be doing the Game of Thrones giveaway week to week
during the off season how ever long it takes to season 8
but lets actually start with that so number 10 their starting
to shoot season 8 like actually film episodes with
the actors in October. That doesn't 100%
confirm that they are going to finish everything by next year and
get it out by the summer but its a strong possibility
There was a big question earlier this year about
how long it was going to take them to write the scripts. There's only
six episodes. It sound like they'll all be longer than an hour
maybe not quite as long as this finale
but maybe close to it. Feature
length is usually something you'd use to describe something that's longer than
an hour. So I'm expecting all the episodes to be
at least longer than an hour but like episode 4
this season was one of the best episodes of the season was shorter
than 50 minutes so episode length isn't necessarily
an indicator of episode quality. But starting
with actually Night King stuff, starting from the end of the episode,
so he makes it south of the Wall. Really what
he's probably going to do is just patrol the North and grab
everybody that he can. What's the
first big thing here south of the Wall? The Last Hearth
so he's probably gonna sweep over most of these minor
houses like Deepwood Motte, the Karhold
but I think the deeper meaning is you get a form of a redemption
for these former traitor houses like you have Alice
Karstark. She and all her people, the Umbers, they might wind up
dying but the Night King is basically just gonna snake
his way south as he gets to Winterfell
Obviously Winterfell is going to be one of the big huge
battles of the season, probably early on by
the middle of the season at least, it depends on how time passes
between episodes. But for those of you asking about Thormund
and Beric, yes, I believe they made it down the
Wall they just didn't show you them escaping but if
you haven't seen the body that means that they are probably still alive
so don't worry about them. They either made it into the bay
and they are sailing south or they made it to the Last
Hearth and that's where they'll pop up next, like Thormund's
too amazing to get rid of in an off-screen moment, so I think that all the
people that died in the Wall coming down are just Red Shirts.
But #9 in service of really great moments
With Tyrion and Cersei, the episode
So we will be able to have an equal balance of both,
but i still think they will try to do at least one big hard-home
style episode, where you are just consumed with the
single plot line, get a really big action-set piece
that also sort of weaves in a little bit of character stuff.
Hard-home is still one of the best, if not the best
big action set piece of the TV show has ever done,
if not best episode out-right.
So I'm gonna cross my finger that they are able to get some of their A list directors, because there were couple of directors
they were not able to bring back this season for scheduling reasons.
So hopefully they can bring back the best of the best
when it comes to making the episodes. But a lot
of those really awesome character moments were just predicated on the odd pairings of people that you don't normally see together
like the hound and brienne, so i am hoping for more of that.
Bran can go anywhere with his mind, and Samwell is a character
that just brings so much comedy with him. But he has
all this knowledge from citadel too.